في احدى التطورات لقضيه سرقه فيلا لاعب
المنتخب المصري ونادي ليفربول محمد صلاح
اعلنت وزاره الداخليه من ساعات انها قبضت
على الحرميه اللي سرقوا الفيلا وقالت
الداخليه المصريه في بيانها انه تم القبض
على شخصين واحد منهم كان بيعمل عنصر امن
في نفس وانه اعترفوا بالسرقه وانه هذا
اللي كان يشتغل سكرتي في الكومباوند وبحكم
سابق عمله فيه عارف مكان الفيلا وعارف انه
ما فيها احد لانهم مو في البلد فخطت مع
الثاني
للسرقه وتسلقوا ونطوا السور الخلفي ودخلوا
الفيلا اما بالنسبه للمسروقات الكثير كان
في تكهنات عنها وانه ممكن يكون من بينها
جائزه افضل لاعب في افريقيا فطلعت
الداخليه واعلنت ان المسروقات كانت مجموعه
من الاحذيه الرياضيه وميداليه فضيه وقطعه
من الكريستال وعدد من اجهزه الرسيفر وانهم
يستدعوا اللي بلغ عن السرقه وهو مدير
اعمال اللاعب وتعرف على المضغوطات وتم
توجيه تهمه او تهمه السرقه للش خصين طبعا
محمد صلاح كانت شغل الناس من كم يوم وقت
انتشرت اخبار وكان ابن خالد اللاعب معدي
من قدام الفيلا وشاف الشباك مكسور فدخل
الفيلا وشاف المكان مكركب فبلغ السلطات
فورا
[موسيقى]